while the research projects at the
Stanford Rock Center is taking a look at
the role of social media for senior
executives and board members what we've
done is a survey of a couple hundred
senior executives and board members
asking them questions about how well do
you understand social media do you do
you use it personally and also you know
what are you actually doing in the
company are you collecting this
information where does it go are you
using it you find it valuable and things
like one of the key findings is that
most of the companies are using social
media but it really doesn't get up to
the senior level or board level it's
basically used for customer outreach a
bit of marketing things like that at the
board level you know you know very very
little I mean the some of the verbatim
responses that we got were this is new
we're not sure what it is seems
interesting it's like you know it's just
another flash in the pan I think the
social media thing scares companies as
well they've seen certain things go
viral
typically viral in a bad way what
happened you know you know why could we
have control that that kind of thing
it's a new technology that there may
actually not that familiar with it's
hard for them to think through the
ramifications of it I think it's also
hard for them to say okay if we do this
you know is there a business case to be
made are we sure that this is value
accretive or not you from our side we
think it is a valuable place for
information there's a lot of topics in
social media that are that map directly
into high-level management in important
structure I think one of the key ones is
all the elements of risk management you
hear things that are that are coming
months or maybe years ahead of time that
would help you it's a reputation of the
organization and at the board level and
worried about risk that sometimes you
get blindsided by I think it is
inevitable
it's got to have an impact on companies
how they attach to their employees how
they attach the suppliers and house and
how they attach to customers we're still
trying to figure out you know what are
what are the steps lots of the company
to do this they're collecting and
analyzing and tracking data and
providing strategies around around
social media what happens when that
information is inside the organization
what does it do what processes are
changed you know can you show that
values being created that's really why
we did the survey what are people doing
people that are making a decision is how
informed are they and things like that
you